Donald Trump in a dangerous
confused all capital letters rant once
again and the question continues to be
is this guy actually running for
president or is he just posting to truth
social essential
and hoping that people show up and beg
him to save the country even though
Republicans don't seem particularly
interested take a look at this
delusional angry Furious all capital
letters rant that he posted to truth
social at least for now resisting
getting back on Twitter quote and
remember it's all caps folks it's caps
all the way down quote how can the
January 6th unselect committee make
criminal referrals when they haven't
spoken about or studied those that
rigged the 2020 election the troops not
being brought in by Pelosi or now the
election fraud determinatively revealed
by Twitter these are the real criminals
I think there's four lies there
uh first of all the committee can make
criminal referrals because house
committees can make criminal referrals
that's number one number two the 2020
election was not rigged number three the
troops were not not brought in by Pelosi
there is no evidence Nancy Pelosi
blocked nor even had the power to
control the troops and there is no
evidence that Donald Trump requested
tens of thousands of troops as he has
claimed to and number three the Twitter
files did not determinatively reveal any
election fraud they revealed that both
the Trump Administration and the Biden
campaign had the email addresses of
people they could email to request
content be removed and if the content
violated Twitter's terms of service
Twitter sometimes removed it Trump
continuing in all capital letters quote
this was election interference the
disinformation nation was coming from
the FBI and Facebook it was coming from
Adam Schiff and Democrat operatives this
was a very damaging story to Biden
before the election and they were going
to kill it bottom line the election was
rigged and stolen Miranda Devine as
interviewed by Mark Levin amazing so
what's the end game here is Trump's
final foray into public life going to be
announcing that he's running in 2024
staying home as he has for the last
month and posting all capital letters
messages to Troth Central to argue about
how unfairly he was treated telling lie
after lie after lie until he eventually
either for health reasons or for some
other undetermined reason says I'm
actually not going to run I have other
things I want to do because this is not
shaping up to be a very successful
political run that's for damn sure and
at some point if he believed Joe Biden
had to leave his house in order to win
which by the way apparently he didn't uh
at some point Trump's going to have to
do something other than just posting all
capital letters messages on Truth
Central now I get it it's early we're 23
months away from the 2024 election but
is this going to be it is this going to
be the last gasp and whimper of Trump's
failed political career I don't know we
will wait and see together
you already know that you need a VPN to
protect your privacy from your internet
provider from Tech platforms from
hackers and you've seen a ton of ads for
different vpns they seem similar which
one do you choose there's really one
thing I look at can it be independently
verified that the VPN isn't logging your
activity that's why when we were looking
for a VPN sponsor we reached out to
private internet access because private
internet access is the only VPN with a
no log policy that has been proven in
court not once but multiple times their
VPN is 100 open source the code is
public their server networks and
management systems are independently
audited by Deloitte to verify there is
no logging with their new next-gen
server setup it's also one of the only
vpns fast enough for stream gaming and
other activities my audience gets
private internet access for 82 percent
off that's just two dollars and eleven
cents a month plus three months free go
to Pia vpn.com Pacman the link is down
below